دانت الخارجيه الامريكيه ما سمته العنف
العشوائيه الذي يشنه مستوطنون اسرائيليون
ضد الفلسطينيين واقل المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه ان الولايات الولايات المتحده
تتوقع من اسرائيل ضمان المساءله الكامله
والمحاكمه القانونيه للمسؤولين عن هذه
الهجمات
ندين العنف العشوائيه واسع النطاق الذي
يشنه المستوطنون ضد المدنيين الفلسطينيين
ووصل الى حد القتل نتوقع من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ضمان المسائله الكامله
والمحاكمه القانونيه للمسؤولين عن هذه
الهجمات
جدد الامين العام للامم المتحده
ادانته بشده لما وصفه بالاعمال الارهابيه
والعنف التي شهدتها حواره ودعا الى محاسبه
الجونه وقال ستيفان دو جاريكا المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده ان
غوتيريش يشدد على وجوب وقف اعمال العنف
والتحريض فورا
يجدد الامين العام والاعراب عن قلق البالغ
من تصاعد العنف في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
ويدير بشده للعنف في حواره ويدعو الى
محاسبه جميع الجناه لا يمكن التبرير
الارهاب او الحرق العمد او اعمال الانتقام
ضد المدنيين تتحمل قوات الامن مسؤوليه
الحفاظ على الامن ومنع الافراد من تطبيق
القانون يشدد الامين العام على وجوب وقف
اعمال العنف والتحريض فورا ويحث جميع
الاطراف على اتخاذ اجراءات لتهدئه الوضع
والامتناع عن الخطوات التي من شانها تاجيج
الوضع المضطرب بالفعل